all right so let's get started okay
hello everyone my name is Metta Tamil
first of all thanks for coming to my
session and today we're gonna talk about
containers kubernetes and Google cloud
this is gonna be an intro-level session
on why containers why humanities and
what ask you but it is really due for
your continuous applications so before I
start my talk talk there's some
information about myself this is my
Twitter so I'm gonna post the slides
after my talk so if you want to slice
just follow me on Twitter and I also
have my email if you have any questions
about any of this stuff I say to that
you can reach out to me at any time and
after my talk I'm gonna go and be at the
experts area so if you have any
questions I'll be there as well I also
have a talk feedback link bitly slash my
last name so if you have any feedback
about my talk please leave them there as
well also today
I'm originally from Cyprus and I live in
London but today I was walking to this
event and I don't know if you guys know
there is a website called 23andme anyone
knows what that is it's basically like a
genetic profiling site so you sign up
and then they send you a kit and you
send your DNA your saliva and then they
tell you where you are from so as I was
walking today I was waiting for that
result for like two months now I got the
results and it said that I'm 75% from
the areas around Cyprus which is not
surprising but 25%
I am from Sardinia that's what I learned
today so I guess I'm 25% Italian in some
way so it's great I think it was a great
place to learn that today so it was kind
of exciting for me anyway so let's think
about software development so when you
think of software development
what does come to your mind first what
does it anyone anyone DevOps okay what
else
software the woman is it fun yes maybe
not so much is it easy
maybe well for me when I think of
software development nowadays I think of
this I think software the women's is
really hard the only people who really
told me that it's not hard is you
the product managers they think that
everything is possible and you should do
you should have done everything
yesterday but if you talk to software
engineers it's it's really like it's
really hard and the thing is it's not
getting any easier you would think that
with the passage of time with the tools
and and cloud and everything things
would get easier but that's not the case
at least in my experience
so anyone remembers these yeah some
people okay it's always good to have
three people to remember these so I'm
not the oldest guy in the room basically
back in the day I didn't use the bigger
ones but I used the small one the one in
the middle back in the day you would
have your ms-dos you will put in your
did your floppy drive you'll close it
you would turn your computer on it will
load the operating system in like a
minute or two and then you would get the
a prompt and then from then on you'll
take the operating system out you'll put
the basic I I think I use cue basic or
gw-basic when I first started
programming and then you would just get
into basic and start coding right and
the thing is there was no internet there
was nothing so this this was literally
the only thing I had to worry about you
know when you think of micro services
there's this notion of bounded context
well back then the context was this disk
and it was like physical you know like
so you could see it you could feel it
and life was really easy you know I
remember like all I had was this disc
and and then I had a book on basic and I
would just look at my book do some stuff
look at my book do some stuff I mean at
some point it was hard because there was
no psych overflow so if you're stuck
yeah there's no one to ask help for but
I like the simplicity of those times
because all I had to worry about was
just I have a problem and I want to
solve that problem since then a lot of
things changed the first thing is
obviously internet and then after the
internet we had all these things that
that happened so we had like
object-oriented programming virtual
machines cloud computing caching machine
learning so it's really impossible to
stay on top of all of this right so what
I try to do as a software engineer is I
pick and choose what I like and try to
learn as much as I can for example
microservices is one thing that I really
like so I try to learn as much as I can
and I'm trying to learn about machine
learning
cause that's where the programming is
gonna evolve into but then I try I also
tried to get an overview while the rest
of the landscape so I so I know what the
landscape is all about right but it is
if it is impossible to learn and know
everything nowadays so nowadays if you
have a problem what you do is you start
with the code again so you write your
code so let's assume that this is the
piece of code that you wrote to solve a
problem it's not on the disk anymore
it's usually hosted on some kind of
server so you find a server somewhere
and host your code it can be your server
maybe or maybe it's some cloud provider
server so it doesn't matter your code
runs on a server somewhere right and
then someone says what happens if that
server goes down what do you do so you
have to have redundancy so what you do
is you basically add a number of servers
it depends how many you want but usually
2/3 is enough and then you run the same
code on those machines but then the
clients they need to know the IPS of
those machines that's not ideal so what
you do is you create a load balancer
that has a stable world virtual IP and
then the clients will talk to the load
balancer and it will get to the machines
as it needs to right so all of a sudden
you know like your code your machines
and your load balancer but then how do
you know your machines are actually
healthy so to do that you what you
usually do is you create what's called a
health endpoint and that we'll check
what it means for your application to be
healthy and then if it's healthy it'll
say okay if it's not healthy it will say
it's not okay but someone has to
actually check these health endpoints
right so what you have is usually a
health checker that will ping these
endpoints and and check whether that
machine is healthy or not and if it's
not healthy you probably want to create
a new machine and add your code there as
well so this is great for for one zone
everything leaves in one zone but you
are relying on a single zone and as we
know even in the cloud some time zones
go down so what do you do you create the
whole set up in a different zone with
the same load balances same machine same
health checking and everything so this
is good so I have redundancy but then
how do I keep the two in sync right so
that's another problem so what you
usually do is you have something in the
middle
you either have like a master or slave
or you have some kind of task you in the
middle where the state from ones
gets replicated too to the other say so
that way they're in sync right so that's
great I have two zones they're
replicated and everything is good but
what if my application is getting really
popular and I need to scale up right you
can scale up manually as you need to but
it's it's difficult because usually
applications they have cyclic graphs so
people use them a lot during the day but
at night they don't use them as much
so usually scale up during the day and
you scale down the room during the night
so no one wants to do that manually so
what you usually do is you create a load
but an auto scaler that will look at
your load somehow and figure out how to
scale up and down right so this is how
it looks like nowadays and it gets much
more complicated than this but this is
kind of like the basic scenario that
unity moment usually and this is for
running a piece of code on an on a
single type of machine if you need to
run different types of applications on
in different languages on different
kinds of machines then you have more
work to do if you want to deploy a new
version of your application then you
need to worry about this whole machines
and end zones and stuff like that so
it's not so easy to deploy your new
version anymore if there's something
wrong with that new version and you need
to roll back to the previous version in
to do that in a consistent and stable
way if you want to do configuration and
secrets over your application you need
to manage them somehow you need to make
sure that they're centrally managed and
you need to somehow get them working
with all the machines in in certain way
and if you need to do scripts because
usually when the machines come up they
usually have some kind of scripts to run
so that's not the code but it's actually
things that make your application work
so you need to manage your scripts as
well so there's all sorts of things that
you need to worry about right now so if
you're like me you're probably feeling
like this guy right now you know you
just want to write some code to solve
some problem but now all of a sudden you
have to deal with all these problems so
the reality of today is kind of like
this you want to care about the code
that you're writing that's what you're
trying to do but then in reality this is
all you're trying to do that you're
trying to create all this infrastructure
so that your code runs in a consistent
stable
and the resilient way basically right
and actually at some in some in one
place that I worked before this ratio or
coding versus operations got so bad for
me that I was spending 90% of my time
trying to manage all of this rather than
writing the code so so this this balance
has to be really really maintained
properly so what do we do well in the
good old days up until recently what we
used to do is that first we write our
code and then we pass that code to QA
for testing because as software
engineers we don't test our code right
that's someone else's job so we will
pass it to QA and say just go ahead and
test this code they will find some bugs
send them to us we will fight back and
forth whether they are bugs or not
eventually we will fix the bugs and if
the QA person is happy then we'll pass
it to operations people and let them
deal with it in in production let them
run it because as software engineers we
don't have to worry about running coding
in production we can just let someone
else worry about that right so we took
this like hands-off approach basically
where we just write our code and just
give it to people for testing and give
it give it to people to run and it's not
really our problem well this didn't
really work so that's why we have DevOps
so I'm sure most of you know what DevOps
is but in in in their office basically
the idea is that you write your code you
test your code you you run your code and
if there's something broken you fix it
and you you basically have the full
lifecycle or your code there are good
things and bad things about DevOps the
good thing is that you have that
feedback loop that you need as a
software engineer to write really good
code because you have an incentive not
to wake up in the middle of the night so
you make sure that your code is
resilient and actually works I seen that
work but then with DevOps you need to
make sure that you have the tools and
the resources and the structure that you
need to to do it right so I seen some
places where they just they just think
that they're doing their ops but what
they're doing is actually they're just
deploying code as fast as possible and
let the code burn in production and then
with that the whole development team
burns as well because they're spending
so much time trying to fix things in
production rather than writing
so what do we do then so if I have to
imagine how software development should
be I think there are three things that I
want to be true the first thing is that
I want as a software engineer I want to
write code in any language I want and I
want that code to run exactly the same
way everywhere right because I don't
want to be constrained by certain
languages and when I run my code on my
laptop I want to make sure that it
exactly runs the same way in the cloud
as well I want this to be true the
second thing is that I want my code to
be optimally deployed somewhere and
managed by someone but I shouldn't
really worry about that myself because
I'm solving problems I'm thinking about
business problems I don't necessarily
need to figure out every single time
where should I put this code or is this
story the right place to put it someone
has to do that for me I mean you would
think that at this point in software
development will get to the point where
this is done for us right and the third
thing is that I don't even want to think
about machines you know like I want to
think about problems and solving those
problems with code I want machines to be
available to me when I need them I want
them to scale up when they need to I
want them to scale down as they need to
if I need some kind of data store I want
them to I want that to be available to
me I shouldn't worry about machines
provisioning machines all the kind of
stuff so this is what I want and if you
look at the last few years in the
industry this we are actually moving in
this direction so when we think about
writing your code in any language and
and running it anywhere
that's basically what containers are all
about so docker and rocket they are
basically trying to create this context
for applications where the context
really transfers from your laptop to
your cloud and your application runs in
that context in a consistent way when we
think about your app being optimally
deployed and managed that's the whole
point of container management platforms
like kubernetes and messes and docker
swarm and things like that so all they
are trying to do is run your containers
in a consistent way anywhere and the
third thing about all the resources
being available when you need them well
that's what the cloud is all about right
so Google Cloud and other other cloud
providers they're all trying to make it
so that
the resources that you need is available
when you need them so we are going in
the right direction and we have chosen
and clouds to do the job so we'll take a
look at Cuban it is today and see how
that provides what we need all right so
now what I'm gonna do is first I want to
build a really simple hello world
service and I'm gonna do that in Google
cloud and then later we'll take this
service and we'll continue is it using
docker and see how that looks like
and once it's containerized we'll take
the container image push it to google
cloud so that we can use it in other
places and then we're gonna create a
cube in this cluster and we'll use that
container increment this cluster so
through that will learn what cube and
this is all about so first let's look at
our service and for this I'm using an
asp.net core application so are there
any donut developers here no okay
well don't net used to run on Windows
and nowhere else but recently a net core
came along and it's basically a
multi-platform version or net that runs
on Windows Linux and Mac and I'm really
impressed by the fact that runs on Linux
so I'm using that in my demos so we'll
use that application as a starting point
for our service but you can use any kind
of application here it's really the
language doesn't really matter so here I
am in Google console this is the main
console to manager projects in Google
Cloud I activate cloud shell this gives
you a development environment in the
cloud so by clicking there I'm basically
getting a Linux box somewhere in the
cloud and I also have a home page where
I can create my application so I am I'm
in the browser and I can access to my
Linux box so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna first so if I just type net that's
the command-line tool to create don't
know applications it's already installed
in cloud shell so I don't have to worry
about that installing that what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna create a folder
for my application I'm gonna call it a
hello world s without net core and then
once I have that folder I'm gonna use
the dotnet command line tool to create a
hello world application so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna say net new - T
web so this creates the web hello world
application and if you look at the files
there's a lot of files that are created
for us programmed ojs is the
entry point to my application so I'm
gonna edit that file and I'm gonna add a
single line to that to the program that
J s to make sure that my application
binds to port 8080 because I want to be
able to test this application from the
browser so to do that I want to make
sure it starts on port 8080 so I'm
adding one line that says use euros an
HTTP star 8080 this way my application
when it starts up it starts on port 8080
so I go back the first thing that I need
to do is net restore so this basically
looks like the project dot JSON file
this is the file that determines the the
dependencies on my application it will
find the dependencies and it will
download them from nougat nougat is the
dependency management platform or not so
we'll go to nougat restore the
dependencies so that I have all the
dependencies here once I have that I can
do the run and this will run the
application on the Linux box and then I
will preview make sure that it works and
once it works we can continue as it so
I'm doing that run so this will compile
the application on Linux and then it
will run it on port 8080 so once we see
the prompt that it's running on port
8080 well we know that the application
is working and there's a nice feature of
cloud shell web preview so if I click
that it will find the Linux box that I'm
running and it will bind to port 8080
automatically so I don't have to worry
about the IPS and stuff like that so now
my app is running on Linux good so
nothing fancy but we'll use this as a
reference app to container sm one
alright so we got our app next step is
containers I mean why should we even
bother with containers so let's try to
answer that question first if you look
at what we used to do up until recently
we used to do something like this we
would have a physical machine we would
we would install the kernel the
operating system on the machine and then
we will install all the tools and
libraries that we need for our
applications and then we'll deploy our
applications on top of that right the
good thing about this is that there was
a single machine single operating system
single set of libraries so it was easy
but then the bad thing is that the
applications they don't have any
isolation whatsoever from each other so
if you change something in the
operating system or if you change
something in the in the libraries you
could potentially break any of these
applications so it was easy to do but
very easy to break as well then we had
virtual machines the the idea with
virtual machines is that you have a
single physical machine but then you you
were chill eyes the operating system and
the libraries or your application so you
put them in a virtual machine the good
thing here is that applications are
totally separate from each other so they
are totally isolated so if you change
something in one place it's not gonna
affect the other place but the bad thing
is that you have four operating systems
and four set of libraries that you need
to worry about so this is a lot of
management overhead so what happened is
that people used virtual machines in in
production but they didn't really use
them as they developed their
applications because it was a pain to do
to manage all the stuff from your laptop
so it was more like a deployment time
kind of thing the virtual machines so
with containers you kind of have best of
both worlds so in containers you have a
single physical machine and a single
operating system but your virtual izing
from libraries up so your application
and its dependencies your virtualizing
to me in what's called the container and
this container is they're much smaller
than virtual machines so they are much
more lightweight so this way it's simple
because it's one one machine one
operating system but it's isolated as
well at the same time so it's combining
the best of both worlds so what is a
container as I mentioned it's a
lightweight way of virtualizing your
applications they are sealed and
isolated so you can have multiple
containers on a single operating system
and they don't interfere with each other
they're easy to deploy so compared to
virtual machines you can deploy stuff to
a container in seconds they're in
they're easy to introspect so you can
actually SSH into the container
look at what's running you can look at
the logs all that kind of stuff and for
me the most important part is composable
they're easy to compose so what you can
have is that there's a base image that
you depend on and then you can build
your image and your application in a
separate image that depends on the base
image and if people need to depend on
your application they can build an image
on top of your image so this way you can
layer your dependencies and this is very
important because that way if someone
depends on you all they have to do is
get your image and build on top of that
so that's nice oh I should also mention
docker is the
main container platform that most people
use but there are others like rocket
from Korres and I'm sure there will be
more going forward and also containers
they might look like there's something
new because we started talking about
them in the last two three years but at
Google we've been running containers for
a long time for more than 12 years
everything in Google Gmail search even
the virtual machines within Google cloud
platform
they run within containers because we
like the security model containers and
we our whole infrastructure is optimized
for containers and actually we launched
more than 2 billion containers per week
so you can see the scale of containers
at Google so now let's take our simple
application and try to continue eyes it
and see how that looks like so here I am
in cultural again I have my application
first what I need to do is I need to put
all my application and its dependencies
into a single DLL so this is a single
package for my application basically
that I'm gonna build to do that I ran
net publish - C release so this will
compile my application it will compile
all of its dependencies and it will
create a single DLL later I'm gonna use
this DLL from docker so doc we'll call
this the other so that's why I'm doing
this so one is this is building a next
step will be to build what's called a
docker file a docker file is basically a
blueprint for an image so it basically
tells docker how to build your image so
we'll create a docker file and we'll
take a look at the dog docker file
because it's very important to see
what's in there so we built already dll
and next we're gonna copy a docker file
that I created into the release folder
and we'll take a look at that so yellow
is built and let's just go to the
release folder where my dll's are I'll
just double check that everything is
there yes I have my dll's I only need
the one that I just built actually so
what I'm gonna do right now is I'm
copying the docker file that I already
created to here and now we're gonna take
a look at that file because it's very
important so let's just pause here for a
second so this docker file the first
line says from Microsoft net10 one
runtime so this is the image that I
depend on
so this is an asp.net core application
and it depends on an image provided by
Microsoft called net10 one runtime so
this is the runtime image that I depend
on the second line says copy dot app so
it says copy everything in this folder
the DLL to the app folder in the
container then work the third line says
working directory app so the app folder
in the container will be the working
directory and then expose 8080 so this
will expose the port 8080 in the
container and in the last the other one
is an environment variable so this is a
sporadic or URLs so I am basically
setting an environment variable to make
sure that my application starts on port
8080 and the last line is entry point so
what happens when the container starts
so here I'm calling net this is the
command line tool to run applications
and I'm pointing to the DLL that I just
built so if you think about it the first
line is my dependency the second through
through the last line is my environment
that I'm setting and the last line is
what happens when the container starts
so with one file I'm basically defining
my dependencies my environment and and
what happens when the container starts
this is great because without this you
have to basically tell people install
this install that set this environment
this way so you have to give all these
instructions and make sure that they
follow it properly but we talk or you
don't have to do that you can just
specify what you want it to be true and
it makes it happen so that's great so
this is the docker file so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna now build an
image from this docker file so the image
will basically look at this this docker
file and it will build an image that we
can use so to do that we use docker
command line tool it's already installed
in cloud shell so we don't have to
install it yourself
so I'm saying docker built - t means tag
my image so I'm tagging it with some
data so you see that I always refers for
Google container repository because I'm
gonna push this image to Google Cloud
container e+ later and then hello don't
let his name on my image and v1 is the
version on my image so it's based on
looking at the docker file and it's
going through the steps the first step
is my dependency what I depend on and
it's a it's an image from Microsoft I
don't have it so we are downloading that
from docker hub
so it's getting the image look from da
crap and it will save it to local Linux
box so we're getting the image and then
once we have that image we'll go through
the other steps we'll set up our we'll
copy files and we'll set up our report
and okay all that kind of stuff so we'll
let that happen so the image is built so
if we actually do docker images we
should see both our both our image and
our dependency image so if you do docker
images the first one is my image and the
second one is the image that I depend on
so they are both on this machine now I
want to run this image make sure that it
works
so to do that I'll do docker run - Dee
means run in the background and then - P
means port so I'm mapping port 8080 on
my machine - port 8080 in the container
and I'm just pointing to my image that I
just built
so this basically runs the image locally
and once this is done I get a code hash
code that tells me it's running if I do
docker PS I see that it's running and
then if I do web preview I should see
the same application but the difference
in this case is that this application is
running within docker everything docker
container basically so there you go the
image is running so the next thing that
we're gonna do is once I had the image
I'm gonna push that image to Google
cloud so I'll do stop to stop my
application and then I'll do G cloud
docker push so this way I'm basically
taking the image that I just built
locally and I'm gonna push it to Google
container repository
all right so we'll fast forward this
because we don't have that much time but
then what you will see is that basically
at the end of this the image will be
pushed and we'll be able to use this
image from Google Cloud so I'll just get
out of here
so containers are good because now I
have an image that I can push it to
anywhere and use it from anywhere so it
gives me the context I need but then to
run this in production there are still
questions that you need to answer for
example if you want to take if you want
to have redundant services you need to
run multiple copies of these containers
so you need to do that yourself if you
want resiliency
you need to create an endpoint if you
want to scale up and down into that
yourself so all the stuff that you need
to do in production you still need to do
that docker or containers they don't
really help for that
so that's when kubernetes comes in so
cuban it is it's it's a Greek word and
it stands for governor actually the
right way of saying to Benitez is given
it is but I guess it started in the US
and everyone calls it wrong but if you
don't learn anything in this talk just
learn that it's called Kievan it is
basically it's it's container management
platform it's hundred percent open
source written and go it's supported by
companies like Google IBM and many other
big companies the greatest thing about
Cuba natives for me is that it runs on
multiple cloud providers so you can have
a Cuban in this cluster that runs on AWS
they can run on Google Cloud and you can
even have a single competitors cluster
that spans multiple cloud providers so
that's the great thing about it it came
from something called bork which is an
internal container management platform
that we use at Google so people who
worked on board they basically learn
from that over the years and they
created kubernetes for everyone else so
at the high level this is how it looks
like so you have a master that that has
multiple things like API servers and its
cities and schedulers and controllers
and then you have noticed that where you
actually schedule containers they talk
through something called couplets and
then as a user you talk to the master
either through API CLI or UI so at the
high level if you want to use cue
Benitez in Google Cloud you would
basically build a an image through a
docker file you push that image to a
Google container registry we just did
that and then from there then only first
you need to create a Cuban in this
cluster so use g-cloud to create a
community this cluster and then from
then on you use cube CTL which is the
command-line tool to manage kubernetes
to schedule your images to to a cube
area this cluster so now let's take a
look at how to create a communities
class during Google Cloud so to first as
you see I push my image and if I go to
Google console and go to container
registry I should see my image or the in
Google cloud so I go here there's
that and then there's different versions
but the version one is the one that I
pushed so now my image lives in the
cloud and I can use it in many different
places one of those is Cuban it is so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna do use
g-cloud again to create the cluster so
I'll say Gigi cloud container cluster is
create and this will create a
communities cluster for me I'll give it
a name so I'll call it hello net cluster
and then I'm gonna specify how many
nodes I want to schedule my containers
so number of nodes is 1 and then machine
types is standard so that there are
different machine types in Google code
that you can use but I'm using standard
machine types here and then I also want
to make sure this class who lives in
Europe West so for zone I'm saying your
West so with this one line now g-cloud
command I will get a cluster with a
master and with a single node where I
can schedule containers and I can use
that to schedule my containers so if you
go to container engine I should see at
some point a classic comes up so let's
just fast forward and at some point I'll
see a cluster coming up and then from
then on I can use the cluster so it's
just one one command basically alright
in the last ten minutes I'm gonna cover
what Kuban it is this so cuban it is it
comes with a lot of building blocks so
this is some of them and there's even
more we won't have time to cover them
all but feel free to stop by so I can
tell you tell you more about them but at
the high level this is how communities
class who looks like you have your
container from your container you create
what's called a part which is either a
single container or multiple containers
different depending on what you want to
do then after that you create something
called replication controller so in
replication controller you basically
tell cube and it is what you want it to
be true here I'm saying replicas three
so I want three copies of this pod
Thank You Benitez we'll look at that and
say okay I need to create three parts it
creates three parts and it schedules
them onto on some nodes but that's
something you don't have to care about
like cuba these figures out where to
schedule these nodes and then once once
these pods are running you can expose
them to that world using what's called a
service so service is kind of like a
load balancer for your parts so the
first thing I want to talk about is
deployment so in cuban it is when you
start you create
it's called a deployment it's basically
a high-level construct that you go you
create and under the covers it creates
all the lower-level things that that's
needed to run your containers so it
creates pods
it tries replica sets and it creates
services for you and we'll look at those
what those are shortly so we'll just
take a look at how to create a
deployment so here I am my cluster is
ready and then I want to basically
schedule my first container to burn it
is first to do that I need to use Kip's
ETL but I need to authenticate this
shell with kubernetes cluster so to do
that I just run a command so once I run
this command my shell is authenticated
with kubernetes and now I can use cube
CTL to manage my command in this cluster
so I'll say ship CTL run and I'll give
my deployment a name so this this is
called hello net and then I'll just
point an image so I push this image from
my machine to Google Cloud so now since
it's single cloud I can easily refer to
that using image and that's it
so I just refer to my image and then I
also want to make sure that the port
8080 is enabled so I'll say port 8080
and then with this we basically created
a deployment in kubernetes so it's just
one command line so if you do keep CTL
get deployment I should see that my
deployment is ready it's very fast and
if I do keep Ct I'll get parts you will
see that I have some pots being created
so you it's just status continue
creating so it's creating the container
and it's trying to schedule it if I do
get pods again I should see the status
running so within few seconds the
content is created and scheduled so
that's great and then there's also
replica set that's been created that
we'll talk about and then there's also a
service that's been created and if you
look at the service there's an internal
IP cluster IP but there's no external IP
because I haven't exposed this pot to
that sort world yet we'll do that next
so as you see all the stuff that I need
is created so I'll just briefly look at
what those the rest of the stuff is so
pods volumes and labels so I just talked
about them briefly so a part is
basically the smallest scheduling unit
in humanities usually you have a single
container in a part but sometimes there
are cases where you
multiple containers in a pot for example
in this case I have a container called
file puller that pulls some files from
some Content Manager and then it says to
a volume and then there's another
container called web server that serves
from the volume to the consumers so I
want the these two containers and their
storage that's called volume to live in
a single unit so that's what a pot is a
pot basically just puts them all
together and kubernetes will schedule
that together and it will kill them
together basically and a volume as I
mentioned it's basically storage for the
pots and you can attach a volume to many
different things like a persistent disk
or something like that so once you have
your pods you can label them labeling is
the way you group things together in
communities so once you attach labels to
your pots you can use selectors to get
your pots so you can say give me all the
pods on my application using this way or
if you want to get all your parts of the
front-end you can say this way oil and
stuff like that so once you have your
pots then you can use something called
replica set replicas that is the
favorite part of kubernetes so you can
think of replica set as a big brother
watching your pots so you won't you tell
what the cat said what you want it to be
true and it makes sure that what you
want is maintained at all times for
example in this case the number of
replicas is 3 and then the there's some
selectors I'm using AB equals demo and
color is a blue or gray so I'm telling
replica said make sure you have three
pumps at all times with these labels and
then it will maintain those pots on some
knows that I don't care about and if any
of these dogs pots go down it will
create an import and schedule down the
node so it will make sure that this is
always true so I have a replica set let
me just show you this like quickly and
this is probably gonna be the last demo
so here I have my pods running so what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna delete this
pot and see what happens
so I'm gonna say keep CTL delete and
then passing the port ID so what happens
right now is replica set is watching my
part so it will detect right away that
the pot is deleted and it will create a
new one so if I do the delete then if I
do get pods again you'll see that
with a new ID has already been created
it says status continue creating so
replicas a watch is basically your part
and as soon as it's deleted or something
it will create a new one and schedule it
within seconds which is good because I
don't have to do that myself
alright and then so you have your pots
your your labels and then you have your
replica set watching your pots now
you're ready to expose your post to the
asteroid world so you'll do that through
what's called services so the idea of
service is that you basically use the
health
selector to select the parts that you
want to expose in this case I am
selecting all the parts that have type
equals Fe so all the parts that have
that label will be exposed behind the
service and the service will have a
stable virtual IP and the clients will
talk to the service to get to the parts
so to actually expose our part it's
again one line of code welcome and so I
have my deployment running I have my
pods running and if I want to expose the
spot all I have to say is keep CTL
expose deployment past my deployment ID
which is hello net and then I will say
type equals load balancer so this will
basically create a load balancing in
Google cloud it will attach that to our
Cuban assist kubernetes cluster and once
the load balancer has an IP we can hit
that IP and it will go through the
service and it will get to the part so
here if I do keep city I'll get service
will see that the external IP is pending
because it's creating a head low policy
right now and I will fast forward
because we don't have that much time at
some point when I do keeps it I get
service I will have an external IP maybe
not here
further down yeah now I have the
external IP so what this means is that
if I hit that IP I will hit the web
balancer and that will wrap me to the
right part so this is the same code
running but it's running within within a
docker container and it's being managed
by Cuban it isso que bonitas watches
that container for us alright I only
have two minutes so that means I have to
speak really fast in the last two
minutes but what I want to tell you is
so scaling in Cuban it is it becomes
really easy so if you have three parts
to scale to four parts all you have to
do is just tell
I said you want four pots and it would
just do it automatically just one line
of code very easy you can sell
auto-scaling so you have your pots you
can deploy something called hipster
which is a really cool name that would
collect all the CPU metrics if that's
what you want and it will report to
replicas app and look as it will look at
the its rules and it will determine if
the CPU target is more than 50% quite a
new part and a note of scale and I have
a demo but I have to skip then you can
do canary deployments so you can have
two replicas sets with two different
kind of versions but you can expose them
behind the same service and do canary
deployments and then you can do rolling
updates so let's say you have a version
one of your application and you want to
create do an update to the version two
you create a new replica set version two
and then add a new part to that and you
expose everything behind the same
service and then and if everything looks
good you take one out here you add one
here you take one out there yeah one
here you take one out there and if
everything works you get rid of the
replica set so to do this in Cuban it is
it's again one command you just say
update do a rolling update and it does
all of this for you automatically so I
haven't up demo but I can show that to
you because we don't have time but feel
free to stop by after the talk and then
there's other stuff there's daemon sells
their jobs there's config Maps and
secrets but we won't cover them here
just know that they're they exist so
there's lots of constructs basically
that make that makes your life easier
when you want to run containers in
production there's even more I didn't
put it here but if you want to learn
more kubernetes dot io is the page to go
if you want to learn about container
engine code google.com slash container
engine and if you want to get the slides
forum on twitter and if you have any
questions i'm gonna be outside at the
experts area thanks a lot for listening